[Music]
there's no denying that technology today
has seeped into every aspect of life not
only is it rapidly changing the world
but also advancing towards making it a
better place to live in from developing
a virtual assistant that helps you in
practically anything
the space exploration technology has
come a long way in recent decades
constant development and technology has
paved way to expand our outlook leading
to some groundbreaking innovations so
let's go ahead and look at the top ten
technologies of 2020 the promise to
build a better future before we begin
make sure you subscribe to our Channel
and click on the bell I never miss an
update from simply love at number 10 we
have wireless power transfer wireless
power transfer is the transmission of
electrical energy without using
conducting wires as a medium it uses
electromagnetic induction over the years
this technology of wireless power
transmission has eliminated the use of
cables and batteries thus increasing the
mobility convenience and safety of an
electronic device for all users wireless
power transfer is useful to power
electrical devices where interconnecting
wires are inconvenient hazardous or are
not possible Samsung why charge energies
corporation Toshiba Panasonic and
Philips have become the leading players
in the global wireless power
transmission market in the future
wireless power transmission is expected
to reach sixteen point three billion
dollars by 2025 from 3.1 billion dollars
in 2017 with the twenty three point one
zero percent CAG are now talking about
the job trends Apple Dish Network Google
Cisco Verizon Wireless extreme networks
are some of the companies that hire for
wireless power transfer computer science
Electrical Engineering thermals and
physics principles Power Systems
proficiency MATLAB Python and experience
in wireless systems are necessary to get
into this field at number 9 we have
augmented and virtual reality augmented
reality is an enhanced version of
reality created by the use of technology
to add digital information to an image
or something virtual reality is defined
as the use of computer technology to
create
environment Facebook has launched new
interactive augmented reality adds to
its newsfeed that lets you play games or
see how the makeup looks on your skin
Apple has been rumored for a long time
to be working on an ear headset a newly
published Apple patent may give us a
better look at what the headset could
look like video games using virtual
reality can be considered as doing some
physical exercise in the future
augmented reality can be used for
transitioning from PC based to
standalone mobile VR devices mapping of
real world to enable persistent air
mirror walls I tracking and facial
expressions built-in for natural
communication VR could also help create
virtual humans to keep the real ones
company talking about job trends Apple
has recently posted a large collection
of job openings calling specifically for
AR and VR expertise jobs range from
graphics system UI system frameworks and
software engineers to an ER or VR demo
evangelist company is hiring for a our
VR our Boston Consulting Group map
systems in data analytics and cognitive
3d you need to have a knowledge of Java
Python MATLAB experience in commercial
software design experience in
high-performance computing software
programming parallel system architecture
and GPU programming at number eight we
have our deep or robotic process
automation IP is the process of
automating anything and everything in
the business operations with the help of
robots to reduce human intervention
robotic process automation is an
evolving technology that is expected to
be mainstream in 2020 it is estimated
that by 2020 40% of large enterprises
will have deployed RPA software up from
less than 10% today by 2020 the global
market for RPA technologies is expected
to grow to 5 billion dollars by 2020 92%
of European businesses will be adopting
robotic process automation technologies
to make structures and processes more
efficient RP is used by just 19% of
corporate controllers but
number is said to grow by 73% of
controllers by 2020 our PA will be
widely used in different domains and
industries like manufacturing retail
analytics aviation oil and gas and legal
also data entry and data wreaking jobs
will be managed with automated tools and
techniques the next stage of our PA will
move beyond rule-based technology and
start to include AI aspects companies
hiring for our PA or Verizon Albertsons
companies Dell NTT DATA and cognizant
Python Java SQL experience in AI machine
learning and Scala are some of the
skills you need to become an RPA
developer in the seventh position we
have quantum computing it is the area of
study on developing computer technology
based on the principles of quantum
theory it explains the nature and
behavior of energy and matter on the
quantum level in 2016 scientists built a
fight qubits fully programmable computer
now it's been upgraded 253 qubits IBM
will soon launch this 50 qubit quantum
computer quantum computer operates on
the atomic level and allows them to
process data at speeds unimaginable to
classical computers that we use in
nowadays China has set up its first
commercial quantum network in the
northern province of Shandong the US NSF
of the National Science Foundation
awarded two million dollars to the
University of Maryland to leave research
on quantum machine learning with
phonetics in the future quantum
computing will solve many areas of
physics that are only theoretically
proven like nuclear physics condensed
matter physics plasma physics and so on
quantum computing has the potential to
revolutionize how we use data and power
machines if we continue like this by
2040 will not have the capability to
power all of the devices in the world
unless we can crack quantum computing
IBM Google General Atomics and
quantitative systems are some of the
companies
hiring for quantum computing experience
with Python get github exposure to quiz
get quantum programming stack developing
numerical models and algorithms
experience designing running and
analyzing algorithms on quantum hardware
are some of the required skills to
explore this field at number 6 we have
IOT or the Internet of Things IOT is a
system of interrelated computing devices
mechanical and digital machines objects
animals of people that are provided with
unique identifiers and the ability to
transfer data over a network without
requiring human to human or human to
computer attraction we'll talk about a
few technological developments in the
field of IOT now IOT benefits the
healthcare sector in a big way sensors
and variable devices can collect and
monitor the data and instantaneously
send it to processing health monitors
transfer analytics by the minute which
can help doctors across the world
analyze and deal with problems cloud
services have become absolutely
essential for IOT deployment these allow
for various devices in an environment to
run cloud services without being
actually connected to the cloud Google
introduced its first self-driving car
under the name of Google vamo way back
in 2017 machine learning AI involvement
and edge analytics all come into play to
make the car operate and analyze the
environment in real-time the future of
IOT has the potential to be limitless
advances to the industrial internet will
be accelerated through increased network
agility integrated AI and the capacity
to deploy automate orchestrate and
secure diverse use cases at hyper scale
as the IOT market continues to grow so
does the IOT job market demand for
highly skilled engineers and other
technical professionals Siemens NTT DATA
ASAP Walmart Accenture and Western
Digital are some of the companies hiring
for IOT masters and computer science
strong analytical and problem-solving
skills
hands-on experience with Python machine
learning and deep learning are some of
the important skills required
will now reach Midway at number five
blockchain blockchain is a distributed
database of immutable records called
blocks which are secured using
cryptography it is currently used to
track and trace compliance regulations
and to build a secure open network for
the drug supply chain by pharmaceutical
companies it is used to verify the
authenticity of artworks to securely
track validate and execute oil and gas
transactions and to reduce the
settlement time the cost of processing
global payments and to increase
transparency of cross-border
transactions based on recent news
blockchain engineers have a 517 percent
increase in demand and the number of
positions have grown more than fivefold
in the past year in 2020 block share
will be used for improved water resource
management and decentralized water use
systems according to Gartner by 2020 at
least five countries will have a
national cryptocurrency it will have the
ability to troubleshoot on chain events
and manage uptime and connectivity even
when some of the components fail blocks
shall be used for data privacy using
identity based encryption company is
hiring for blockchain our Deloitte KPMG
cognizant ebuy consulting and Verizon
experience working with C C++ Python
relational and noise fill databases
cryptography large code bases and
internet security are some of the skill
sets that you need to become a
blockchain developer at number four we
have natural language processing and
voice technology advancements in
computer science has made it possible
for humans to interact with machines in
their natural language either in written
or spoken manner this is possible with
the help of NLP natural language
generation or energy and natural
language understanding or NL you are the
two main components of NLP natural
language processing helps organisations
reduce customer effort improve the
organization's analytical capabilities
and enable advanced automation
earlier NLP was limited only to text
messages now it has become more popular
for voice as well it can understand the
language emotion and sentiment of what a
person is writing or talking about it
helps in the space of automatic speech
recognition and natural language
processing in Indic languages for
building voice assistance and for speech
analytics NLP is also used to scan users
email inboxes for signs of meeting
requests with an app called woven it's
virtual assistant generates suggested
times to meet and send emails to
attendees to select a time option
according to research by Gartner
1/4 of all companies will have
integrated a virtual customer assistant
or a chat bot using some form of NLP
into their customer service by 2020 in
the future NLP will be used for email
assistance which is autocorrect grammar
of spellcheck air chat BOTS sign AI
which is a sign language translator and
predictive police work NLP in healthcare
and life sciences is projected to grow
at the cagr of 21.2%
between 2080 and 2025 companies hiring
for NLP and voice technology are JP
Morgan Microsoft Amazon Dell Target and
so on our text mining machine learning
deep learning and much more are some of
the requirements of NLP and now we're at
the top three number three is cloud
computing cloud computing is the process
of using a network of remote servers
hosted on the internet to store manage
and process data rather than a local
server or a personal computer earlier
cloud computing had only three general
models software as a service platform as
a service and infrastructure as a
service
now cloud computing has X AES which is
everything as a service it also includes
disaster recovery as a service
communication of the service and network
and service cloud computing is expected
to provide the digital infrastructure
for smart cities with the cloud data is
transformed into small data and manage
tech virtual data
time will be required by applications to
process this data data will be better
secured and easy to manage because the
cloud is centralized the results of data
analysis will be more accurate
eighty-three percent of enterprise
workloads will be in the cloud by 2020
fifty percent of IT professionals
believe that AI and machine learning
play a significant role in cloud
computing adoption to date growing to 67
percent by 2020 companies hiring for
cloud computing are JP Morgan Honeywell
IBM Wells Fargo Google and Amazon AWS r
is your certification knowledge of
RedHat ec2 V PC PC and DevOps an
automation experience are the skills
required to start a career in cloud
computing and now we're at the top two
number two is Phi G Phi G is the fifth
generation of cellular technology this
expected to provide Internet connections
that are at least 40 times faster than
4G LTE Phi G would significantly improve
the bandwidth capacity and reliability
of cellular broadband far more than
previous generation shifts Phi G will be
used in developments of mixed reality
smart factories and smart cities Phi G
technology enables edge computing
architecture edge computing is the
practice of processing data near the
edge of your network where data is
generated rather than a centralized data
processing warehouse by 2035 it is
estimated that Phi G will enable twelve
point three trillion dollars of global
economic output in the future with that
profile G there'll be a ten-time
decrease in latency ten times increase
in connection density three times
increase in spectrum efficiency and a
hundred times increase in traffic
capacity in the u.s. the big four
carriers AT&T Sprint t-mobile and
Verizon will begin rolling out 5g
networks in 2019 and 2020 reliance Gio
and Chinese telecom firms China Mobile
China Unicom
and many others have joined hands for 5g
technology company is hiring for Fajr
Verizon Nokia Motorola Qualcomm
and Samsung Electronics experience in
wireless communication technologies
knowledge of communication theory signal
processing machine learning MATLAB
C C++ shell scripting and so on are some
of the skills required to start a career
in this field and finally on top of the
hierarchy we have artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
an area of computer science and
emphasizes on the creation of
intelligent machines that work and act
like humans it's now being used in
almost every business sector to reduce
human intervention it is also a major
role to play in cybersecurity and
digital marketing 69% of IT executives
say that they cannot respond to cyber
security threats without artificial
intelligence air improves the accuracy
of detecting breaches increases the
efficiency of cyber security analysts
reduces the time they spend analyzing
fake positives and improves productivity
in digital marketing air is being used
to predict the behavior of a customer
delivering a personalized experience to
the user and unlocking new opportunities
for marketers it is expected that in the
future air and robotics will come
together and a will help create fully
functional robots air driven virtual
assistants will anticipate your needs
and fulfill them without the need to
give them any instructions many in the
tech industry and displayed AI driven
applications allowing machines to
recognize your face to complete
transactions research is already
underway to develop new software
applications that use AI
to help doctors diagnose and treat
patients Google Microsoft IBM Dell
Amazon Baidu
and Boeing are some of the important
companies hiring for AI may the skills
required to become an engineer
our Python our machine learning deep
learning tensorflow
data science SQL and bi tools and with
that we've reached the end of this video
if you enjoyed this video do like and
share it thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]
you